[Musique]
bonjour pas un journal télévisé depuis
quelques semaines dans lequel on entend
parler de l'affaire clear stream mais
clear stream c'est quoi
une lessiveuse mystérieuse d'argent sal
la clé de bien des affaires de
narcotrafic de trafic
d'armes et ou de mondialisation et de
licenciement notre invité aujourd'hui
est Denis Robert journaliste écrivain
artiste auteur il y a 10 ans d'une
enquête sur Clearstream Clearstream
c'est une chambre de compensation
financière basée au Luxembourg qui était
alors inconnu du grand public et dont il
dénoncer les agissements troubl
aujourd'hui tout le monde en France
connaît clear stream c'est devenu
évidemment synonyme de d'État 10 ans de
bataille judiciaire 60 procès des
centaines d'huissers à votre porte de
solides illimitiés dans le monde
politique tout de même il en reste
également parmi vos nos confrères le
milieu de la presse et puis un éclair et
puis la nuit aprèsdant voilà le 3
février 2011 c'est encore tout frais
tout récent la Cour de cassation vous
planch définitivement et reconnais dans
votre travail votre travail alors de
journalistes et
d'enquêteurs les finances de la presse
d'un point de vue économique c'est une
catastrophe au niveau de la presse
papier ça c'est évident je je j'ai j'ai
déjeuné avec un ami tout à l'heure les
ventes du nouvel Ops par exemple ont
baissé de de les ventes du PO ont baissé
de 16 % le dernier trimestre celles de
l'OPS ont baissé de 14 et L'Express qui
a fait une Rance à baissé de 10
libération est en situation
catastrophique c'est même plus c'est la
respiration artificielle à leur niveau
le ça vient de quoi ça vient de quoi ça
vient de Deah il y a l'Internet qui est
venu tout bouffer quoi et puis ça ça
vient aussi des contenus qui sont à
vendre qui qui correspondent plus on va
dire naïvement au désir des des des
lecteurs ou des gens quiens est-ce que
tu penses que c'est une perte de
confiance des lecteurs des auditeurs
face à la presse en
général ce que je crois c'est que
d'abord il y a une offre qui est
considérable que l'information est noyée
dans cette offre donc c'est très
compliqué l'actualité c'est facile
l'information c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué donc il faut la recouper enfin
tout ça ça demande du travail du temps
et
puis comment dire l'offre qui est
proposée ne correspond plus visiblement
dans des lignes très larges au désir des
des des des lecteurs ou des acheteurs de
journaux ou des abonnés enfin donc on
voit qu'il y a une espèce d'affaissement
comme ça ceci dit c'est pas c'est pas un
drame c'est un mini drame c'est c'est
une tendance c'est lourd c'est compliqué
mais en même temps comment dire il y a
une responsabilité des des des des
patrons de presse des journalistes donc
je vais pas pleurer avec tout le monde
c'est comme ça voilà au niveau de la
confiance oui non tu penses que la
population le client de presse est-ce
qu'il a perdu confiance dans dans sa
presse c'est difficile de répondre sur
ce type de question c'est des
généralités je pense que d'une manière
générale oui je pense qu'il y a un
manque de confiance ceci dit l'affaire
kahusac pour parler d'elle à montrer que
que les les que quand tu as une volonté
journalistique forte tu arrives à à
renverser des des des des des pouvoirs
et et en même temps c'est aussi un
contreisemple parce que c'est c'est
médiap part ils ont eu contre la presse
quoi
et je vouis comprendre vous avez été
auditionné aujourd'hui au Sénat à
l'Assemblée nationale
et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous leur
avez
dit c'est des c'est vraiment une une
mission parlementaire sur le sur le
journalisme et la protection des sources
c'est le point de départ mais c'est un
peu plus vaste que la protection des
sources donc c'est c'était une une une
conversation qui a duré 1 heure où on
m'a beaucoup interrogé sur sur
clirestream sur et sur les difficultés
que j'avais eu personnellement et si tu
veux enfin si vous voulez une une de mes
parmi les idées que j'ai développé en
fait on peut pas on peut pas isoler le
problème de la protection des sources de
l'ensemble des problèmes de la
protection du journalisme parce que
parler des sources c'est parler des
problèmes de diffamation de droit à
l'image c'est parler de la loi gesso
c'est parler de la liberté d'expression
c'est parler de tout ça donc c'est un
tout on est la profession est en perte
de repère est en perte d'identité en
même temps le monde avance plus vite
qu'elle quoi donc il y a des il y a des
réajustement il y a des règles il y a
des tas de questions qui se posent il y
a des gens qui veulent créer un ordre
des journalistes il y a des gens qui
veulent créer une espèce de Haute
Autorité de de la presse numérique avec
qui qui qui serait à l'instar de la
Haute Autorité de l'audiovisuel il y a
il y a des il y a des projets de loi qui
peuvent être hyper protecteurs pour le
journalistme qui se font au détriment de
de de de d' d'autres choses de de de de
il y a aussi la les gens qui se sentent
qui se sentent insultés ou baffoués par
des articles ont le droit de se défendre
c'est une question d'e d'une complexité
assez importante et donc c'est c'est
c'est ces députés essa de de de de de
trouver un chemin dans tout ça ils ont
une démarche qui me semble cohérente et
honnête et en France on est en retard
par rapport à des pays comme la Belgique
par exemple qui qui eux on ont choisi
des chemins je sais parce que j'étis
entendu par des des commissions en
Belgique là ils veulent créer un délit
de presse qui est spécifique fill qui
veulent il y il y a des tas de trucs qui
circulent en ce moment et il y a des et
et je pense que que que François
Hollande indépendamment de tout le reste
c'est quelqu'un qui est beaucoup moins
liberticide que l'était Sarkozi quoi en
la matière donc donc la volonté de ces
députés je pense qu'ils sont conscient
que que qu'en ce moment il y a des y a
des bouleversements il y a des choses
qui se passent et que et que et que on
peut pas se contenter de dire laissons
faire les choses mais qu'en même temps
dès que tu touches à à un aspect du truc
c'est c'est c'est un truc qui est très
fragile parce que c'est ça devient très
vite liberticide ou ça devient c'est la
porte ouverte aussi à toutes les les
conneries qu'on voit sur internet donc
donc ils vous ont beaucoup interrogé sur
clirestam parce que il y avait une
méconnaissance du dossier il y avait une
méconnaissance de la technique
journalistique d'investigation non mais
ce qui se passe c'est que moi je suis le
le le le le parfait exemple je pense
qu'il a il y a pas d'autres a très peu
d'autres exemples de de ce que ce que
les Canadiens appellent les procédures
Bayons c'est-à-dire que vous vous êtes
bombardé de procès et Infiné même si
vous gagnez vous vous vous vous perdez
quoi parce que le temps que vous passez
à vous défendre le
temps le monde avance et puis il y a il
y a un espèce de rouleau compresseur
comme ça donc comment empêcher ces ces
pleint temps moi j'ai jamais dit que
même clirestream même les plus pourris
des pourris ont le droit d'attaquer en
diffamation c'est un jeu normal il y a
une justice les juges jugent les
journalistes font leur job les écrivains
leur enfin parce qu'après il y a des
problèmes de différence de de statut
entre journaliste écrivain tout ça est
un peu compliqué aussi et en face bon
simplement là on voit bien que quand on
est face à des des oligopoles ou à des
ou à des multinationales ou à des mecs
blindés de pognons qui qui qui se font
attaquer dans la presse que ce so sur
Internet ou ou dans les papiers les
types déposent des plaintes déposent des
plaintes et après vous êtes comme dans
une partie de pingpong vous avez qu'une
raquette vous êtes face à à des joueurs
dans tous les pays c'est c'est ce qui
m'est arrivé donc comment empêcher ça
alors que légalement ils ont le droit de
le faire donc moi j'ai je je pense qu'il
faut imaginer soit de changer la loi sur
la diffamation c'est-à-dire que de plus
demander d'argent au journalistesfin il
y a des choses à faire mais moi ce que
je préconise c'est un truc un petit peu
compliqué c'est ce que j'ai essaé de
défendre à l'Assemblée c'est que quand
parce que je me suis retrouvé souvent
dans ce cas de figure de type qui vous
qui vous assène des procès qui vous
demande un maximum de pogon que quand en
gros je je le fais court mais après il
faut trouver les termes juridiques quand
l'histoire vous donne raison parce que
ça prend toujours du temps la vérité les
types qui vous demandent du blé B il
faut multiplier par 10 par 20 par par
100 ce qu' vous ont demandé au bénéfice
du du du journaliste comme ça ils
hésiteront avant de déposer des plaintes
et et parce que il y a un risque pour
eux aussi s'ils perdent parce que le
problème des diffamations c'est que les
types qui déposent des plaintes quand
ils perdent euh ou quand ils racontent
des conneries quand ils assènent des
accusations qui sont fausses ben eux
s'en foutent ou même la veille d'un
procès ils peuvent retirer leur plainte
ceci dit les dégâts sont sont déjà là
quoi donc je je je crois qu'il faut être
il faut être inventif offensif sur ces
ces questions là parce que un des une
une des des des je vous donne un exemple
dans à Paris au tribunal dans le le le
comment dire la cour qui s'occupe des
des procès en diffamation il y a 3 ans
le le il y a pas 3 ans il y a en 2000 au
début des années 2000 quand j'ai sorti
mes bouquins euh ça mettait en gros 2
ans de 2 à 3 ans entre le moment où
quelqu'un déposait plainte en
diffamation et le moment où la plainte
était ou instruite ou jugée il se
passait entre 2 et 3 ans CIT des très
très long aujourd'hui il se passe entre
deux et 3 mois donc on pourrait penser
que c'est VO la justice va mieux ça
fonctionne bien mais pas du tout c'est
parce qu'il y a de moins en moins de
procédure en diffamation et il y en a de
moins en moins c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle ça veut dire que les éditeurs
de presse ou les journalistes ou les ont
tellement peur maintenant des même plus
de perdre des procès mais ils ont peur
des procès parce que les procédures ch
évidemment il y a une autocensure et il
y a une censure et ça c'est dramatique
c'est-à-dire que la la la la liberté
d'expression et la démocrati souffre de
ça donc et donc je je je suis un espèce
de vigile comme ça qui dit faut
faire attention quoi parce que voilà
même si parce que les batailles que j'ai
mené judiciaairement qui ont duré 10
années pour moi et que j'ai fini par
gagner ce sont des batailles qui qui
sont emblématiques mais je les ai mené
pour pour pour un ensemble de d'autres
journalistes de gens qui qui sont
soucieux de cette liberté et c'était
plus important à un moment donné parce
que on m'a souvent peut-être reproché de
de moi j'ai même plus trop envie d'en
parler mais la raison pour laquelle je
me suis battu judiciaairement c'est pour
créer cette jurisprudence qui existe
aujourd'hui et qui offre plus de liberté
aux uns et aux autres simplement il faut
que ça il faut que ça ça avance quoi
donc est-ce que le fait que les
journalistes ne présentent pas les
chiffres correctement ou d'une façon
enjolée ou
enouleuse induit unefaiture du
journaliste ou un défaut d'information
mais bien sûr ENF votre question
contient la réponse quoi évidemment
évidemment la la la la presse vous
parlez de presse économique disons la la
presse financière et sans doute la
presse la plus inféodée et qui soit au
au aux banques et au et aux groupe
financier j'ai y a il y a j'ai je pense
que la presse financi le journalisme
financier j'ai peut-être être comment
dire être lapidaire dans mon propos mais
n'existe pas c'estd que il y a il y a il
y a que des des des des des journaux en
fait bah prenant le les échos euh ils
essaient de faire leur boulot mais c'est
c'est c'est quand même pas terrible
c'est mieux que que queun certain nombre
d'autres titres mais mais c'est pas
terrible et et les les pages financières
du Figaro comme celle du monde on voit
bien que derrière il y a des groupes de
pression des groupes de presse et cetera
et que euh on est d'une manière générale
bombardé d'indices de chiffres de Bours
et tout qui sont complètement falsifiés
c'est-à-dire que qu' il y a il y a un
espèce de grand mensonge autour de tout
ça et je crois pas au complot je crois
pas à tout ça mais je je sais très bien
que ces journaux sont payés par par
Arnaud par Pino par et par et par les
banques et qu'il y a des annonceurs et
qu'il y a tout ça et que et qu'on peut
pas déplaire quoi et je l'ai vu avec
clstam c'était le SOMUM quoi parce que
parce que c'était voilà à l'époque où j
a enfin je vais pas reparler de ça
d'ailleurs je m'interd à parler de ça
donc les législateurs s'informment par
l'intermédiaire aussi de la presse donc
au niveau de d'une d'une intoxication un
défaut d'information il y a très peu de
manières pour
s'informer en dehors de la presse mis à
part les blogs donc là je vous emmène
sur le les blogs la loi on on contraint
les blogueurs au même devoir que les
journalistes on se on est on sera
condamné pareil on sera jugé pareil sauf
qu'on a pas de carte de presse comment
vous expliquez ça quel est votre point
de ça ça ça fait partie des des des des
des questions qu'on m'a posé aujourd'hui
ça demande beaucoup de temps beaucoup de
moi je suis pas je je je pense que toute
toute réponse à ça sera imparfaite parce
qu'en même temps on peut pas considérer
que n'importe quel Pékin qui se met sur
internet à commencer un proférer des
injures ou à raconter n'importe quoi
voilà il il doit être soumis à des à des
règles et à des je veux dire si moi je
me sens diffamé il faut que je puisse
l'attaquer ou je ça me plairait pas
qu'on me traite de de je sais pas moi de
pédophile ou de ou qu'on invente des
histoires sur moi dans dans truc je veux
dire il y a il y a l'internet c'est pas
le foutoir quoi donc il il y a besoin de
de de de de il faut des règles il c'est
comme ça je veux dire il faut des règles
pour les victimes comme pour il y a il y
a il y a un problème de ça on peut pas
non plus dire liberté totale enfin et
cetera alors que moi je suis plus grand
adepte de la liberté d'expression mais à
un moment donné je suis aussi conscient
de de de la la complexité de tout ça
donc j'ai pas de solution puisquon m'a
interrogé aujourd'hui là-dessus pour moi
c'est pas une obsession de penser à ça
mais ce que je ce que je pense c'est que
c'est que qui a une une sorte d'autorité
morale enfin comme la Haute Autorité de
l'audiovisuel qui puisse euh comment
dire être une espèce de de chambre de
compensation ou de ou de ou d'instance
d'appel quand il y a des des des des
problèmes ça peut peut-être fonctionner
ça je suis pas sûr que ça soit la
panacée mais il y il y a un truc à
imaginer autour de ça je
m'explique j'ai j'ai il y a des tas de
gens je vais vous donner des exemples je
me il y a des des gens qui je me
souviens d'un type qui je crois que
c'est dans la région Grenoble qui avait
fait des qui avait qui était pas du tout
journaliste mais qui qui qui était je
crois éducateur ou infirmier et qui
passait ses weekends ou son temps à
travailler pour un site et qui avait
filmé des manif des policiers qui
tabassaient des femmes dans une manif et
les policiers ont porté plainte ils ont
dit que le truc a été manipulé et le
type a été poursuivi il a été condamné
et cetera il avait pas eu de carte de
presse la Commission de la carte l'a pas
défendu et il s'est retrouvé à poil et
sans rien ce type il faut le défendre
parce
que il est peut-être sans doute plus
journaliste qu'un éditeorist du Figaro
qui écrit n'importe quoi ou de ou d'un
autre canard je dis Figaro ça peut être
un canard de GA j'en ai rien à
c'est pas ça et donc il y a il y a il
fait œuvre de journalisme il fait œuvre
mais mais comment mesurer ça parce qu'à
côté vous avez un type qui va sortir une
fois de chez lui avec son iPhone qui va
filmer un type qu' aime pas et puis il
va inventer une histoire autour de ça il
va être poursuivi ça sera normal qu'il
soit condamné donc il y a il y a et
comme rien n'existe on peut pas tout le
temps se protéger derrière ça il y a un
autre problème c'est je je je suis
considéré en tout cas comme un
journaliste ou ou on m'invite dans les
écoles on vous m'interviewez des choses
comme ça j'ai pas de carte de presse moi
depuis 4 an 80 on me l'a retiré en 95
enfin en 97 parce que mes droits
d'auteur étaient supérieurs au gain que
j'avais dans les entreprises de presse
j'ai même fait
un j'étais j'ai créé une jurisprudence
au niveau de la carte de presse puisque
j'ai j'ai prouvé que même si on était
auteur donc on m'a rendu ma carte de
presse pendant 2 années puis après comme
j'ai écrit des romans et des trucs je
l'ai plus mais donc on voit bien que de
dire qu'un journaliste c'est uniquement
quelqu'un dont les revenus parce que
c'est ça la définition d'un journaliste
aujourd'hui en France c'est plus de 50 %
de ses revenus doivent venir d'une
entreprise de presse mais ça veut dire
que vous avez des directeurs de com des
fois qui ont des cartes de presse moi ça
à l'époque c'est pour ça que j'avais
fait ce ce procès entre guillemets à la
carte de presse et vous avez vous avez
un autre débat moi qui m'a hérissé c'est
c'est toute l'histoire avec Bachelot là
et et la bande de filles là de de Direct
8 là comment il s'appelle je sais plus
Ferrari la la la nana plus l'autre enfin
Bachelot a commencé à ouvrir sa gueule
pour dire attendez nous c'est normal
qu'on ait une carte de presse parce que
on fait un travail de journaliste et
cetera la Commission de la carte leur a
dit non et alors B Chel a expliqué que
euh alors elle a eu un truc elle a dit
mais regardez c'est ces types sont des
tacherons c'est des mecs les types de la
Commission de la carte comme ils sont
pas en pleine lumière comme nous euh par
frustration il nous empêche d'avoir la
carte et et donc elle a elle a essayé de
développer l'idée que quand on faisait
du divertissement on méritait la carte
de presse aussi je pense que c'est c'est
une hérésie quoi et que il est normal
que ces gens-là ces filles-l ça serait
des mec très pareil n'ai pas leur carte
de presse parce qu'elles font du
divertissement parce qu'elle raconte des
conneries à la télé enfin je sais pas
quoi et donc l'énervement qu'elle a eu
était était surfait et si elle voulait
une carte de presse elle avait qu'à
faire comme moi elle avait qu'à faire
une mesurer demander une dérogation et
et et il y aurait un un jugement à un
moment donné il faut décider si des gens
sont capables d'avoir une carte de
presse ou pas et et et je je pense que
la la la la la Commission de la carte
n'a pas les moyens de ses ambitions mais
heureusement que que des journalistes
c'est c'est soutiers de l'info ou c'est
ou c'est galèr rien des des types qui en
dehors de leurs heures sont à la
Commission de la carte heureusement
qu'ils sont là pour tenir un peu la
boutique mais je pense qu'il faudrait
les aider je pense qu'il faudrait
renforcer l'arsenal alors c'est très
compliqué parce qu'après vous créez tout
de suite un conseil de l'ordre comme
chez les médecins et c'est pas ce qui
est demandé donc il faut trouver il faut
trouver quelque chose une il faut sur ce
qui existe déjà pour créer un un un ce
que j'ai appelé la chambre de
compensation peut-être des journalistes
c'est dire qu' un endroit où où tout ce
qui est litigieux et problématique
puisse être jugé par sorte de sage qui
serait alors après le problème de les
nommer par des l'Assemblée nationale les
journalistes et tout ça ça créer des
castes ça cré tout ça il faudrait
trouver un moyen démocratique et
acceptter par tous de créer cette cette
C cette commission qui soit pas comme la
Haute autorité qui est quand même un
espèce de truc où les mecs viennent
tirer du blé parce que parce qu'ils ont
rendu des services quoi et donc je
trouve pas ça terrible non plus mais il
y a il y a des choses comme ça à
inventer de toute manière la démocratie
on on en est au début de ces questionsl
on pourra plus faire l'économie de se
les se les poser il va falloir
vraiment mais parce que parce que il va
y avoir tellement d'injustice et il y en
a déjà tellement qui profilent que si le
législateur et si les les professionnels
ou les n'essaent pas de de de de de
proposer des choses et de réfléchir à
tout ça on va vers des des mini
catastrophes qui vont peut-être en
amener des grandes quoi on voudrait
votre avis sur l'affaire
snowdeni ce ce jeune j'ai trouvé
incroyable que la France lui donne pas
lui donne pas l'asile cétait justice
mais là on est dans la géopolitique on
est dans la réale politique et on est
dans voilà on s'attaque pas impunément
aux États-Unis quoi j'ai pas mal lu
là-dessus donc j'ai lu des choses assez
des choses même dans des journaux je
crois que j'ai d ça dans Rolling Stone
on expliquait que Ston était un
activiste de droite qui avait des des
des propos
complètement on essaie de de qu'il soit
de droite ou de gauche franchement je
m'en fous quoi ce type il faut lui
donner une médaille comme il faut donner
une une médaille à comment il s'appelle
Bradley maning et évidemment à Sange
plus à Bradley maning à Sange ce sont
des ce sont des imérit des prix Nobel de
la liberté c'est des gens qu'il faut
qu'il faut voilà il faut le il faut leur
monter des statutes il faut les il faut
c'est il faut il faut les accueillir en
France bras ouverts quoi parce que c'est
quand même incroyable le type démontre à
quel point les Américains nous ont
écouté enfin d'une manière ce qu'on
savait ce qu'on su budoré mais là on le
lit on le voit et vous avez ces espèce
de de de de type qui font les mur là on
les voit bien les les types du pouvoir
là qui pas trop se cogier sur la
question quoi et et je trouve ça je
trouve ça moi j'ai voté pour eux mais je
voterai peut-être encore à gauche
évidemment mais c'est insupportable
c'est insupportable et et ces gens font
de la politique mais ils font pas la
politique donc ils ont aucun courage ils
ont aucune et ils sont en train de de de
vendre leur âme ils ont perdu ils sont
en train de perdre perdre toutes les
batailles c'est marrant parce qu'il les
perdent de toute une à une je regardais
encore manuel Vals il y a une vidéo qui
tourne sur Internet 3 qu jours là il est
interpellé par une femme à à trappe
c'est incroyable cette vidéo faut la
regarder quoi Val c'est complètement
minable il est minable il a pas le
courage de regarder cette femme en face
qui dit des choses des évidences quoi et
et là on voit le le le socialisme au
pouvoir à quel point il est compromis à
quel point il est il est il est il a
peur de son nombre quoi enfin ça se
passe voilà c'est il y a un climat de
malaise qui instauré par ces gens-là
quoi et vous vous adressez quand même à
eux pour financer votre projet chaîne
documentaire
mais c'est pas non je m'adresse pas à
eux c'est pas ça j'ai fait une j'ai
l'idée de la chaîne documentaire c'està
je passe d' du cocalan euh quand je vois
les merdes qu'il y a à la télé sur ces
chaînes quand je vois que l'argent publ
ça sert à payer gully à la chaîne des
momes ou que que même mon mom qui est
prêt à regarder dessins animés japonais
il supporte pas que que que quand je
vois que ça va dans France 4 pour des
des animateurs à la con qui savent même
pas parler français c'est pas le
problème de Paris français où ça paye
des des des des séries américaines avec
le quart du budget d'argent public de ce
truc là on ferait une vraie chaîne de
doc ce que j'ai appelé doc doc TV je
veux dire avec beaucoup moins d'argent
je pense qu'on peut créer un truc
formidable et qui peut in Infiné et à
terme à moyen ou long terme concurrencer
des trucs comme youtube ou ou ou les
projets comme Google TV qui se dessinent
et cetera donc il faudrait créer et j'ai
besoin des je trouve que c'est normal
dans un dans une démocratie comme
celle-là avec la gauche au pouvoir qu'un
ministre de la
Culture puisse puisque c'est des
conversations que j'ai eu avec elle
puisse aider ça lui ferait du bien
d'ailleurs d'avoir un bon projet parce
que pour l'instant elle est elle nous
elle défend un certain nombre de d'idées
et cetera mais je la vois pas avoir des
projets incroyables et ce projetl est un
bon projet et que de l'argent public
puisse servir à ça ça me semble juste et
bon d'autant que je je termine là-dessus
si vous saviez le nombre de
documentaires incroyables qu'il y a dans
les caves et les belle de France
Télévision et d'aré vous seriez sur le
cul quoi parce que c'est ces chaînes
comme elles fonctionnent avec de
l'argent public elles ont besoin de je
le sais parce que je suis producteur de
doc donc je vois bien comment ça marche
les films passent une fois on les oublie
alors qu'ils sont là et il y a des tas
de gens qui pourraent les voir dans les
lycées dans les écoles dans les facultés
il y a des des choses formidables à
inventer là-dessus c'est pour ça qu'avec
mes deux trois copains voilà Alain de
Greff Lionel Bordeaux enfin et d'autres
on a on a on a imaginé ce ce ce ce ce ce
cette plateforme associée la la chaîne
de télé c'est une vitrine donc voilà
l'argent public oui l'argent public il
vaut mieux qu'elle serve à ça plutôt que
de payer des des séries téléaméricaines
c'était ça l'idée n'est-ce pas une
manière de rester un petit
peu affilié voir un peu inféodé à la
politique en cours de se faire en
financer uniquement par ce ce biais là
alors que vous pourriez également vous
faire financer par le biais du public
donc qui sont vos propres et également
Metz ça avec une par exemple une
production un peu la Kickstarter qui
permettrait de financer d'autres
documentaire c'est quoi bah pardon en
fait vous postez un projet ah oui et
selon l'intérêt du public le chacun met
un dollars enfin et CER de nouveau
documentaires d'accord ça je je vois ce
que je voulais dire mais dans le projet
de doc dooG TV il y a l'idé c'est c'est
un projet de film payant très peu cher
mais quand on veut regarder les
documentaires donc il y a des vitrine o
il y a des des film Gratuit et puis il y
a une espèce de banque de données
immense et quand on veut les voir mais
on paye 1 € 2 € on peut s'abonner enfin
il y a tout un système comme ça donc il
y a pas c'est pas uniquement de l'argent
public mais pour initier tout ça le
documentaire étant un l'art du savoir
étant l'art de la connaissance c'est
pour ça que je pense que ces
documentaires nous quand on on fait des
documentaires on a tellement de mal à
les faire et on y met une part du cœur
de l'âme enfin et cetera qu'on a envie
de les distribuer quand moi je vais dans
des dans des lycées ou dans des
universités pour montrer mes mes mes doc
les salles sont blindées quoi ça crée
des débats je peux pas passer ma vie à
ça c'est pour ça que cette plateforme ça
pourrait être formidable ceci dit a
telle lourdeur Philippe ettier est
entouré d'énarc elle est entouré de et
puis elle a d'autres choses à penser
donc c'est pour ça que je lui ai fait
cette lettre ouverte je pense que ça lui
a pas beaucoup plu ceci dit voilà c'est
comme une bouteille à la mer je sais pas
si elle l'entendra je pense pas
d'ailleurs je pense que il va falloir
qu'on se débrouille autrement et donc là
le net rentre en
jeu faire de la pub sur internet pour
une chaîne éducative qui porte des
valeurs les valeurs de l'intérêt
général ça renforce une population dans
son intellect dans sa façon de critiquer
quand en face nous avons un dogme
journalistique je je prends le dogme
journalistique le dogme journalistique
économique quand les gens apprennent via
Internet VI des documentaires sérieux
par rapport à des économistes paumé
Enouf fond de berclay qui s'adresse
vraiment à la communauté de l'Internet
est-ce que vous pense pensis pas que les
législateurs français n'ont aucun
intérêt à produire une chaîne éducative
qui pourrait renforcer l'esprit critique
d'une
population non je je je pense que le
comment vous dire il faut se garder de
de de de jugement comme ça trop globaux
je pense que que Vincent payon est un
meilleur ministre que Luc Chatel par
exemple je je préfère je voter je pense
que que fait ce gouvernement pour pour
l'éducation est plus intéressant que ce
que faisait le précédent en plus moi le
but c'est pas de faire une chaîne du
savoir c'est c'est de de diffuser de
d'offrir une vitrine à des milliers de
documentaires qui sont oubliés et et et
je pronostique on va pas faire peut-être
des chiffres d'audienceces formidables
au début mais je je je pense que que que
des des jeunes gens des adolescents ou
même des enfants sont intéressés par la
par l'art du documentaire qu'est-ce que
vous pensez d'un documentaire sur
Coca-Cola qui va mettre à mal des
législateurs par rapport à la régulation
de de X substances chimiquees est-ce que
vous connaissez l'ampleur de la pression
qui a été faite sur les éditeurs ce
documentaire j'ai entendu parler de
l'histoire ou qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire sur la pression que reçoivent
les réalisateurs de documentaires sur
des sujets tchi qui engagent des
législateurs alors c'est le le
problème la question du documentaire est
compliquée parce que en France on est
hyper privilégié j'ai des copains
espagnols qui viennent en France pour
financer leur film il y a plus un
centime là-bas quoi en France on est
privilégé parce qu'on a le CNC alors je
sais que c'est très critiqué qui qu' y a
des castes là-bas qu'il y a des gens qui
qui se prennent moi je je suis pas un un
je trouve qu'on a une une formule qui
fonctionne et qui est qui est plutôt pas
mal simplement il y a des sujets casse-
guueule et et moi il y a des films que
que j'ai voulu faire un film sur Cavana
c'est impossible de faire financer un
film sur Cavana je suis obligé de passer
par du crowdfunding ou des choses comme
ça mais il y a des sujets des sujets en
France quand on on traite de la finance
comme je l'ai traité avec Clearstream
quand on traite d'une l'industrie du
nucléaire quand on va vraiment au fond
du truc quand on on on est sur les
ventes d'armes quand on est sur
l'agroalimentaire
fait ils font des trucs pas mal mais
c'est souvent des trucs un peu
historiques qui prennent du temps quand
on s'attaque à des multinationales comme
ça Robin l'a fait avec monsantau par
exemple c'est le même problème que alors
elle elle elle a elle a trouvé un
système maintenant qui est vachement
bien c'est que et ça c'est la force
d'internet c'est les souscriptions
c'est-à-dire que il faut avoir un nom
faut avoir des projets qui se tiennent
et et on arrive à financer des des des
des choses comme ça et le film sur
Coca-Cola il va être vu en plus il y a
des je pense que c'est un c'est comment
dire c'est une évidence pour moi de dire
ça c'est qu'une démocratie c'est c'est
c'est vous savez c'est des bioryythmes
une démocratie a besoin d'information a
besoin de documentaire et quand on on la
on muselle tout ça quand on essaie de
fermer les vannes il y a toujours des
endroits par où ça sort donc on va
trouver des réseaux de cinéma
indépendant on va trouver des il y a
internet quoi voilà ils peuvent rien
contre
internet pas encore ils peuvent rien sur
internet non mais il pouront rien ils
peuvent faire toutes les lois qu'il
veulent je dire on les emmerde quoi ils
y arriveront
pas
le déterminant de l'affaire kahusac
c'est kahusac des types comme kahusac il
y en a pas il y en a pas beaucoup cette
espèce d'aplon incroyable avec lequel
les les yeux dans les yeux de tout le
monde il a dit je ne mens pas vous
pouvez me croire et cetera il y avait un
truc je me suis dit ce type c'est je
veux dire moi j'ai je l'ai cru et je
l'ai cru alors peut-être j'avais un a
priori par rapport à pleinel je sais à
quel point ce type a très envie de tout
et donc je me ça à plus à un moment
donné j'ai dit j'ai un doute moi
là-dessus quoi mais après à partir du
moment où il y a eu la bande en plus
Arfi un journaliste plutôt sérieux donc
j'ai j'étais j'étais comment dire
j'étais je me posais beaucoup de
questions là-dessus puis moi je
j'enquiétais pas j'avais des des sources
de tout le monde et et et donc et
l'affaire kahusac au départ le le truc
c'est kahusac quoi sa personnalité cette
espèce je l'ai encore vu à l'Assemblée
là le type est incroyable il a un espèce
d'apelom je pense que que des Kusa qui
en a pas beaucoup dans les dans les dans
les générations de de de de politique
quoi et c'est aussi ça qui pose un
problème ce dit vous voyez c'est c'est
un un formidable parce que kusac c'est
une très bonne nouvelle c'estàd que s'il
avait pas eu kusac parce que
souvenons-nous de de de discours de
François Hollande au Bourget moi quand
j'ai vu François Hollande au Bourget
s'attaqué à la finance enfin et cetera
je trouvais ça pas mal mais je sentais
le gros coup de bluff en plus c'est
là-dessus qui gagne beaucoup les
élections parce qu'en face il avait un
Sarkozi sur l'histoire des banques il
était minable Sarkozi payé par Goldman
sax Sarkozy qui qui va faire le petit
télégraphiste partout enfin qui qui d'un
côté essaie de défendre la France puis
d'un autre côté se vend au banquier
enfin Sarkozi c'était quand même l'homme
des banques enfin il a on dit qu'il a
sauvé le système bancaire mais enfin bon
il a aussi enrichi enfin bon et donc en
faceit vous avez un candidat socialiste
qui ressort des tons enfin avec un ton
qu'on a vu qui était presque gaulien et
et et en fait il a rien fait quoi les
paradis fiscaux l'autre nous a expliqué
Sarkozi il y a quelques années que ça
est il y avait plus de paradis fiscaux
mon œil ils se sont jamais portés aussi
bien et donc je l'ai écrit je l'ai dit
je peux le démontrer je peux vraiment
vous parlez de ça longuement parce que
je connais bien la question et là vous
avez Hollande moi dès Hollande il en a
rien à de la question des paradis
fiscaux c'est du discours c'était une
manière de de d'être au pouvoir et là le
problème qu'il a alors ils font des
petits trucs à Bruxelles mais sous
prétexte que Merkel le le si sils
avaient vraiment une volonté politique
forte de lutter contre les paradis
fiscaux ils avaient ils ont toute
l'attitude pour le faire il ne le font
pas il ne l'a pas fait la bonne nouvelle
de l'affaire kusac pour bah il ne l'a
pas fait parce qu'ils sont je pense
lié pas pas d'une manière corruptive
mais que autour d'eux il y a tout un
environnement politique où on voit les
les les les liens entre entre la finance
tien par la barbichette ouais en gros en
gros c'est ça mais ce qui intéressant
avec kusac c'est que le psychodrame
kusac c'est que pendant 3 mois il a
serré les dents le mec a menti à
l'opinion puis vous avez médiap part qui
bastonnait derrière plinel le procureur
général enfin et puis médiap part à
Fabri ce
psychodrame positivement presque parce
qu'à la fin il gagne et le type lâche et
là vous avez quand même un ministre du
Budget le principal chasseur de la
fraudte fiscale qui est quand même dans
le leadership du du du pouvoir qui qui
qui a menti alors après il dit qu'il a
menti au président enfin la commission
d'enquête est en train de de de
d'étudier tout ça vous avez cet homme
qui explique qu'il a un compte en Suisse
qu'il a fraudé et cetera qui s'excuse et
cetera mais le mal est fait et donc à ce
moment là la réaction du pouvoir elle
est assez bonne parce que comment
voulez-vous qu'il fasse donc bon il
virent la brebie galeleuse et ils disent
je vous promets la main sur le cœur on
va changer enfin et cetera et ça les
oblige cette situation les oblige à ne
pas faire que du discours donc et
d'ailleurs il entraîne avec avec lui
Cameron parce que Cameron en Angleterre
ils ont aussi des problèmes donc là j'ai
vu que ça bougeit un petit peu près de
la City mais très vite voyez on en parle
un petit peu moi alors on dit qu'il va y
avoir parce que cette histoire de cette
histoire de de de comment dire de la
communication sur l'information fiscale
d'un pays à l'autre c'était en 96 le
texte de l'Appel de Genève si vous le
reprenez c'était exactement ça donc en
96 on est en en 20 en 30 ans il s'est il
s'est pas passé 31 ans il s'est rien
passé quoi de de de fondamental et là
vous on a l'impression quand on lit les
papiers et cetera que c'est en train de
bouger que c'est en train de changer pas
du tout vous avez deux pays qui refuse
c'est l'Autriche et le Luxembourg et
vous avez la City qui dit qu'il accepte
donc Londres en fait ils ont pas envie
d'accepter non plus donc toutes ces
c'est que vous avez des des embrasements
médiatiques comme ça puis après vous
avez un travail de fond à Bruxelles vous
avez 3 400 ou 500 lobby bancaires pour
un lobby qui est on va dire antibancaire
qui est Finance Watch là mais il y a une
force de le principal pouvoir c'est
quand même le pouvoir des banques quoi
c'est quand même des gens qui qui font
des holdup permanents et nous font
croire que que c'est nous qui volons
l'argent quoi enfin c'est des trucs
incroyables et le pouvoir se laisse
prendre par ça et et les journalistes
aussi mais évidemment les journalistes
aussi évidemment évidemment mais c'est
pour ça que pour moi bon là je réponds à
vos questions parce que bon voilà vous
m'avez appelé je je vous connais un peu
donc je me dis allez c'est 1 heure de
mon temps et cetera mais je je en même
temps je trouve ça relativement 20 quoi
c'est-à-dire que je sais on sait je sais
plus ou moins ce qui va se passer quoi
dire que voilà ce qui va se passer c'est
les affaires continu quoi et et en même
temps moi je crois au livres je crois à
l'information je crois au documentaire
donc moi mon rôle c'est d'expliquer des
choses et puis simplement moi je suis un
je suis quelqu'un de je suis la mauvaise
conscience du journalisme un petit peu
parce que voilà pendant 10 ans je me
suis battu je fini par gagner mais bon
voilà puis en plus je demande rien moi
je m'en fous des médailles je m'en fous
de tout ça je je simplement je je pense
que
euh que que ma marginalité relative
c'est c'est pas moi qui ai changé moi
j'ai pas changé je suis le même que
quand j'étais à Libération c'est j'ai
j'ai une éthique j'ai une déontologie
j'ai voilà après j'ai changé j'ai j'ai
eu plusieurs vies j'ai fait t de choses
mais c'est autour de moi qu'il y a eu
des renoncements des glissements c'est
le le le je je je voilà dans un moment
libération il y a eu de la publicité
après il y a eu des pages de finances on
nous a dit que c'était l'évolution puis
on a on a enlevé le courrier des
lecteurs et puis voilà puis on a vendu
libération à un Banquier puis puis je
continue à le lire d'ailleurs parce que
je trouve de fois de bon papier mais on
voit quand même que le niveau a baissé
quoi
considérablement et justement euh vous
parliez de niveau tout à l'heure avec
euh les les l'économie le fait que les
journalistes viennent la plupart du
temps d'un cursus littéraire euh ne les
empêche-t-il pas d'avoir un véritable
expet critique sur l'économie par
exemple euh sur laquelle ils seront
formés par des économistes mainstream
pour le coup euh divulgant je crois je
crois qu'aujourd'hui un journaliste qui
a pas lu Frédéric Lordon c'est pas un
bon journaliste quoi donc je suis pas
sûr que les les mainstream soient et la
coach et les journalistes je pense que
le fait d'être littéraire c'est plutôt
une qualité par rapport mais en même
temps moi j'ai fait j'ai participé à des
sélections de de de d'école de
journalistes et je vois bien les les les
profils sont tellement divers quoi mais
ce qui frappe surtout c'est d'ailleurs
un des un des trucs que je développe
dans la série documentaire que je viens
de faire c'est c'est la quantité
incroyable chaque année de de postulants
au boulot quoi vous avez je raconte dans
mon film qu'à l'agon il y avait 3000
2900 je crois l'annon qui est un inité
de journal en Bretagne il y a eu 2900
postulants en 2010 pour 30 postes 30 30
étudiants en première année quoi dans et
malgré la la journaliste le journaliste
c'est la profession la plus déccriée en
ce moment aux États-Unis vous avez un
journal avait une crise terrible les les
les salaires des journalistes ont baissé
et il y a eu une une étude faite par un
site d'offre
d'emploi qui qui explique que enfin ils
ont fait un test mais sur un grand
nombre de personnes je crois qu'il y
avait 40 ou 50000 personnes qui ont
répondu au test c'estàdire quels sont
les les les les boulots que vous
préférez comment et pourquoi
journalistes je crois qu'ils arrivent
alors il y a les 30 boulots préférés et
il y a les 30 boulots détestés et
journaliste c'est 29e donc c'est le
presque le je crois que derrière
journaliste il y a bûcheron dans les
boulots détestés quoi mais les mecs
préfèrent aller travailler dans le
pétrole être secrétaire aller se prendre
une balle en Afghanistan plutôt qu'être
journaliste parce que c'est une
population ça gagne pas de sous c'est
précaire et c'est la merde quoi aux
États-Unis et en France on n'est pas
encore là il y a toujours Laura Albert
Londres des voilà mais au journalistes
vous allez aux États-Unis vous parlez de
du Washington enfin de comment des
hommes du président tout le monde a
oublié quoi enfin fa faire baisser les
salaires des journalistes est-ce que
c'est une façon comme une autre de les
rendre encore plus précaire et de les
rendre encore plus malléable
c'est-à-dire de tendre la laisse du
pouvoir sur leur collier c'est ce que a
dénoncé al Ricardo il y a 15 ans dans
son dans un de ses livres à un Cardo
c'est un formidable
sociologue c'est lui qui a qui a premier
dévpper l'idée des media workers quoi on
en est on est en plein dans les media
workers euh
c'est-à-dire on est sur Internet surt ça
des papiers plus signés plus plus signés
par des gens qui sont des stacanovic de
l'info ou les Chivas de l'info qui
filment qui truc qui doiv faire trois
papiers par jour qui sont qu'est-ce que
vous voulez vous faites vous faites de
l'actualité mais vous faites pas
d'information donc c'est c'est moins le
problème des salaires qu' que le
problème d'un système quoi et je sais de
quoi je parle puisque je suis en train
d'essayer en ce moment de créer un un un
un un un un portail internet enfin qui
va s'appeler info du jour où on va on
essaie d'embaucher des journalistes on
va essayer parce que j'étais parti sur
l'idée que de de l'internet gratuit moi
marchant sur la publicité et cetera et
et j'en suis revenu je pense
qu'aujourd'hui devant le d'ailleurs la
la presse quotidienne régionale est en
train de sombrer et la la presse
nationale est est dans très mauvaise
santé donc il il y a de l'espace pour un
un journalise de qualité et je prends le
pari que des des des les gens vont
s'abonner de plus plus en plus à des
sites d'information mais il faut être
bon il faut amener une valeur ajoutée il
faut être sérieux rigoureux il faut
travailler donc et ça ça se paye et si
ça marche pas ben ça marchera pas mais
en tout cas pardon on va on se lance
dans cette aventure en ce moment enfin
j'y travaille dernière question pour
finir si vous aviez un un conseil à
laisser une bouteille à la mer à laisser
sur Internet pour les jeunesses qui nous
regardent quel conseil pour affuter leur
esprit critique j' ajouterai une petite
un petit un petit plus quel serait le le
serment du journaliste en version
2013 le non mais c'est c'est de de de de
rester curieux c'est que l'information
c'est c'est comme une truff qu'on va
chercher quoi ça ça prend du
temps c'est c'est il faut jamais croire
ce qu'on nous dit le ont étant les
médias les politiques et ce mais en même
temps il faut pas non plus voir des
complots
partout queour journaliste ça reste un
métier indispensable on ne s'improvise
pas journaliste
mais par contre tout le monde peut peut
être journaliste à force de travail et
et d'un travail sur soi et d'un travail
de d'acculturation c'estd pour être
journaliste il faut être cultivé il faut
lire il faut s'intéresser à l'actualité
il faut lire des livres très important
la littérature je dire moi moi je
j'apprend plus le journalisme en lisant
Tom Wolf ou ou même Richard brotigan
qu'en lisant des essais ou des ou des
panflets enfin donc donc il y a voilà
c'est d'un c'est c'est c'est d'une
grande
complexité et c'était alors est-ce que
je je pense que c'était sans doute plus
facile il y a quelques années pour pour
pour pour gagner sa vie en étant jisque
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est c'est sans
doute plus difficile et encore je pense
qu'on est dans une c'est difficile en ce
moment parce que on est dans un un monde
est en train de s'effondrer on si les
gens ne l'ont pas vu c'est qu'ils sont
aveugles mais les quand on est un peu au
cœur des des systèmes on voit bien qu'il
y a un effondrement permanent enfin et
et en même temps des choses sont en
train de renaître euh et et et on va
arriver sans doute à une sorte de de
rééquilibrage parce qu'encore une fois
une démocratie peut pas vivre sans
information alors est-ce qu'elle peut
vivre sans journaliste je pense pas moi
je ne pense pas parce que des
journalistes sont les sont les les
garants de cette information après c'est
sur la définition de qui ils sont c'est
certainement pas claire Chazal qui pour
moi est pas une personne détestable est
d'un commerce agréable mais pour moi
c'est pas une c'est pas parelle que le
journalisme c'est pas l'avenir du
journalisme c'est la fin ce journalisme
donc il y a des journalismes qui qui
émergent d'un petit peu partout mais il
faut voilà il faut hiérarchiser il faut
le web est une est un est un est un
monde encore en en devenir quoi mais il
faut pas oublier non plus qu'aujourd'hui
ben le journal de 20H fait 8 ou 9
millions de de de gens qui le regardent
les radios sont très écouté le le net
est pas c'est pas la panacée mais mais
on sait très bien que dans 20 ou 30 ans
bon bah voilà tout viendra de
là de
rien
d'ultralibéralisme ou de
libertarisme qui consiste à dire en gros
il y a une main invisible du marché qui
surtout veut dire mais attendez n'ayez
comme seul comportement personnel d'être
égoïste en fait prisme c'est juste un un
sous-programme particulier d'un plan
plus général autrefois ça s'appelait ça
s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans le un
programme que l'on conna qui s'appelle
échelon alors les ni les Russes ni les
Chinois n'ont envie que l'ONU se
transforme en une machine à donner les
bons et les mauvais points de
gouvernance
[Musique]
et